[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est un jour important
problème liquide parce que nous
inaugurons un campus d'innovation avec
un centre de recherche que l'on voit
aujourd'hui
pourquoi l'innovation est importante
pour nous parce qu'on a toujours compris
que la différenciation du groupe était
d'être capable d'innover en permanence
et ceci depuis plus d'un siècle
alors qu appelons-nous innovation la
capacité que nous avons à traduire notre
connaissance scientifique sur des
petites molécules essentielles jusqu'à
la mise sur le marché et pour faire ce
long voyage de la science business comme
on dit il faut être capable d'animer
tout un écosystème des académiques des
technologues des business et la mise en
opération et nous avons conçu ce centre
pour être accueillants pour être ouverts
pour permettre à cet écosystème très
large d'exister entre des chercheurs
entre des personnes qui développent les
applications et qui les mettent sur le
marché et à la fin des clients et le
tout proche de ce qu'on appelle les
académiques sur ceux qui ont la capacité
à nous ouvrir encore plus loin vers la
science
[Musique]
quand on 70 je remonte loin en 70 on a
mis ce centre de recherche
ici tout le monde disait c'est rodin de
paris regardez 48 ans après paris sacre
est arrivé c'est une formidable
opportunité pour nous parce que quelque
part on voit arriver ici des universités
des grandes entreprises une notoriété
internationale
donc c'est une divine surprise alors
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous avons reformé heureux remis au goût
du jour je dirais 60 de recherche et ce
campus d'innovation
parce que nous voulions être je dirais
en synchronisation parfaite avec 7
ce cluster encore une fois d'une
réputation internationale indéniable
l'innovation ouverte l'écosystème mais
il faut le faire vivre
il faut avoir des alliances j'en ai
plusieurs en tête qui assistent mix il
ya peu ps il ya la fabrication additive
on regarde donc à chaque fois qu'est ce
qu'on essaie de faire
on essaye de mettre des clients des
partenaires des universités ensemble et
on essaie de créer un écosystème
réserver assez assez assez initiative
est donc on voit apparaître
effectivement toute une série de micro
écosystèmes à l'intérieur de ce vaste
écosystème qu'est paris saclay
[Musique]
et